what's up amanda how are you doing yes
i'm a schoolteacher
and i've been march tired since november
well i used to teach school too so i got
i you know i mean
yes for those of you who know what march
tired is when you wake up every day and
think
i'm pretty much dead and i got to go to
work and be there at 6 20 so that i can
do tutoring so then i can
do hauled pass duty so then i can
actually teach my class and then grade
the papers and call the mean parents
back
and listen to stupid administrators and
then go home and repeat
oh i'm sorry no then go do bus duty and
then go grade all the papers and then
it's 7 30 and i call
whoever i love at home and say i'm not
coming home because i hate my life and
then i'm going to repeat
that's the march okay so go ahead go
ahead amanda
okay so i've heard you talk to other
teachers about how to offload your
bricks and all that kind of stuff my
question is a little different
i think um i like to tell people we can
do a lot in march and april because we
know june and july is coming we know
that
the natural rhythm of offloading as a
season
is right around the corner you know
we've got spring break coming and then
graduation and then and and then summer
and but but the problem is the the hope
of
of that break isn't there because we're
in this
this coven season and so you know
there's there's
the goal line keeps moving you know
first it was two weeks then it was
six weeks then it was the election
somehow was gonna make it all better and
then once we get past flu season
you know then it'll all die back down
and now we're past flu season and
now there's this vaccine but wait a
minute it's not available for kids yet
and so
it's like the goal post that that gives
us hope that this is going to be over
soon
keeps moving and we're seeing i mean
i'm high school so we're seeing like
tragedy after i mean
um you know kids just dropping out and i
feel like
i'm not trying to belittle by any means
the nursing profession but i feel like
i'm losing patient after patient because
you lay yourself out there for these
kids you're
you're you're accommodating you're
you're pushing deadlines you're giving
them
retry after retry your you know
accommodations this and that and the
other
and then they still go nah i'm glad i'll
see y'all next year you know or i'm out
i'm going to do something different
for me i'm a career in technical
educators so i teach business and
finance and
and how to get a job and communication
and so i feel like my classes are
are giving some kind of hope to the kids
because they can walk out the door and
go get a job and do
something right now but i have you know
i feel a little bit of this my my
faculty members say a little bit of this
and i just don't know what to do like
you're burnt out yeah well and and like
ken coleman says
i don't feel like it's it's built it's
build up no it's and there's nowhere to
put it
because there's no end in sight and even
our
high achieving kids are losing faith in
themselves because
you know our ap kids our high achievers
they're getting ready for college well
i don't want to go to college because
it's all virtual now that's that's not
what i signed up for
yep yeah and so now they're not even
showing up and so
i mean i just don't know what to do so
um kelly told me this call was coming
and i actually
um i've got a there's a relatively new
book out
um and it's called burnout the secret to
unlocking the stress cycle by emily
nagoski and she's a
woman and her sister wrote it too with
her emily nagusky
and amelia but she's a health educator
and
she paints burnout in a picture that i
haven't heard it painted before
and it was this idea of it's three parts
emotional exhaustion this
i this fatigue for caring for everybody
for too long
and then this depersonalization like i'm
just out
i don't have any more empathy or care or
compassion left in my body
and then this was the the big one this
decreased sense of accomplishment this
futility
it doesn't matter what i'm doing they're
just gonna drop out right
so here's the challenge with that some
of that is real
and some of it's not and it begins to
paint like when you go looking for
dragons in the clouds you're always
going to find them
you're always going to be able to find a
dragon a cloud whether it's actually
there or not
the more you go looking for dragons more
you're going to find dragons and
it that begins to loop because then you
get more and more disconnected it just
becomes futile which then you get more
emotionally exhausted and it just spins
on itself right
so here's a broader question
what what are other things you like
doing besides teaching
and i'm going to loop all the way back
around to your students i'll get there
but what do you like doing besides
teaching
is that rhetorical are you asking no
that's a straight-up question oh
um i love going to the gym okay um just
exercising usually
are you a crossfitter please say yes
please say yes please say yes no
i was i'm an ex professional athlete
i'm a weightlifter oh okay sweet awesome
um
so you care about your joints and things
like that good for you okay
i try yeah there you go so you like
going to the gym
what are parts of okay forget the
outcomes by the way we'll just cut to it
you have tied your heart and soul to the
outcome here
and one of the the the challenges of
teaching
is i think is they put these
short-sighted metrics on the
relationship between a teacher and their
students
can they bubble in the right 13 answers
on this 14 answer test
this quiz that says they can x y and z
when it comes to chemistry or
industrial tech or fill in the blank
whatever um
whatever subject we're talking about in
my estimation
that demeans and belittles and reduces
the relationship between a teacher
and a student between care and love and
wonder with a subject to this can you
get to this stage so i can put you in
this track to get you to this room so
you can get to that thing
and we've we've just sucked the soul out
of education we've made it this big roi
it's it's nonsense what we've done to it
and so
stripping all the outcomes away what do
you love about teaching why are you even
doing this job
you clearly care about those kids why
are you doing this
yeah i mean for me in my content area
it's it's
listening to them open their first bank
account
or helping them fill out their
application for their first job or
hearing the shenanigans about why they
got fired from their first job and how
can we
fix that you can actually be employed
later like i know that what i'm teaching
is gonna help them in their lifetime
regardless of what they plan to do yeah
you know and it's hard because on one
hand we hear a voice going
they're kids they need boundaries they
need to be held accountable no matter
what i know we can do it i know they can
do it
and then you have this whole other voice
going but it's a pandemic
give them a break right and
intellectually
anybody who's looking at this from the
outside knows there's going to be a
decade more of fallout from this last 18
months
i mean it's just going to be you want to
create if you wanted to create
a way to torture a generation of
children
besides murdering their parents it would
be to lock them in a room and have them
start a screen for a calendar here with
no
human reason human interaction yeah
we've done it and we're going to live
with it for years and years and years
i'm not saying it's the wrong thing i'm
saying there's going to be fallout for
years and years and years from this
they will remain you know and and having
to retrain students how to do school
again that's right
how did you communicate with one another
how to sit there and be connected yes
it's going to be hard it's going to be
hard
here's the thing though when you're
burnt out and you're fried
what you start doing is looking for the
next dragon and the next dragon and the
next dragon and what you're doing now is
you're taking on the pain
and future frustration of kids
experiences a decade
from now and you're dragging that pain
in the future that may or may not exist
and you are
setting it in your soul right now does
that make sense
and you're carrying whether they're
going to be able to get a job tomorrow
and what they're going to do at the end
of this thing and what's july going to
look like we've been coming back in the
fall
you've got all these things down the
road that because you're exhausted and
because you are
completely burnt out you have no empathy
or care left and dude i'm with you
i'm exhausted right um and because you
feel like a cog in a feudal machine
okay cool let's just throw it online
because that's the same right
the the natural thing you start doing is
running on a treadmill and just trying
to grab
future pain and future pain and future
pain and grab it and pull it and drag it
and so here's the thing you've got to do
you've got to back way the heck up
forget about the bricks you got to back
up and say
i've got to be okay so that i can head
back into this
because what you just told me is i love
interacting with these students
i love hearing about what they want to
do when they fell on their face i'm
there to
either laugh at them when they're trying
to crawl up or i help pick them up and
dust them off
and are both of them right and i love it
when they get their first job i love it
when they have a place to go after they
get fired from their second job right
that's who you are man you can't fully
be
that when you're carrying future pain a
decade down the road that doesn't exist
yet
and the only way to not go down that
road and i'm
talking as somebody who has been there i
had to leave a university and take a
break because i kept doing that
these kids are going to be this is going
to be the future of this is going to be
if you guys
i got lost in tomorrow and i was unable
to
be effective in my today and what
happened was i burned everyone out
around me i stopped doing the things
that i loved because i was too busy
trying to
prevent the things that were going to
happen down the road right
and so dr znagosky one of the things
they
here's the three things they say and i
love the way they say it because they're
writing two women in this book by the
way it's great for men too but they're
writing to women we'll put links to the
show notes here
they say rest is resistance
for a professional woman who's trying to
help other people
this idea that i have to unplug and take
a break
especially as a teacher i cannot change
the outcomes of young people
to my identity to my day-to-day
functioning or you'll drown
right the second one is how often are
have you stopped going to the gym are
you still getting there
oh no i'm going every four days a week
good okay so the
another big one is you gotta move your
body movement is resistant so good for
you
is there a way that that has become
weightlifting has become an addiction
meaning is it time to go just for walks
is it time to pick up running do
something else that's going to stretch
your body and challenge you in new ways
that are going to also be able to help
decompress
and get the same cardiovascular and
physical and structural benefits
i've been in that space before but i
don't think i'm there now okay all right
so there's been times when i have to go
to the gym not i get to go to the gym
oh yeah for sure okay um and then
finally
you circling back and remembering why
you're doing what you're doing
and what you love about it and here's a
cool benefit my wife
is she's a she's a coach she works with
teachers
and she's for years she's been a
professor who worked with teachers
and pre-service teachers and now she
works with teachers who are burned out
and fried and cooked
and one of the things she always
challenges them to say what are the
parts of teaching that you love
and how can you do more of that what are
the parts of teaching that you hate
and how can you do less of that what do
you think
give me one of each what's something you
love that you could do more of
just honestly i just miss the
conversations with the kids i mean my
content so
every day and i miss them when they're
not there
you know and they're not there and i
can't make
every student i haven't seen in three
weeks but she hasn't withdrawn yet it's
like
i worry about them when they're gone do
they
have a daily journal that they write
that you read and
write back to them back and forth to one
another
no okay so starting monday it's going to
be a small writing prompt that you're
going to give them and say i want to
know
three things like how you're doing um
what are you excited about and what are
you terrified about
and that's a way that you can engage
them whether they're in class they're
out of class
they're going to keep coming back to
this thing especially because you're
going to respond to each and every one
of those
and it's going to be a little more time
but it's the thing that you love
sure you love hearing their stories
that's what you love
what's something you hate about all this
grading paper there you go so here's the
thing
i'm giving you on behalf of the students
and teachers of america i'm giving you a
pass
give less work we're all about the
psychological stuff at this point
especially with what you're doing right
you're preparing people's hearts and
minds for the workforce
and so yeah figure out a way to give
less work
no student has ever been said that the
teacher came in is like you know what
we're not doing
papers anymore we're going to do this
right that's true
and so find the things that you love do
more of them
create con average news for conversation
i loved
the my wife actually taught me that
exercise she did it with her students
and i started with my graduate students
and it ended up being magic how's today
what are you grateful for where things
are going awesome and what scares the
crappity about tomorrow
in reading those in writing i got to
learn deeper about my students got to
learn more and shape my class in a
pretty profound way
but also i'm like you i just love
hearing people's stories i don't care if
you're a plumber or
or fancy pants i like hearing stories so
i'm going to set that up
and i like you i hate grading papers so
i'm going to only give one paper a
semester because i hate grading papers
right
i'm gonna i'm begged to hire i've begged
them to let me hire a graduate assistant
but they won't let me do it yeah they'll
never let you do that
high school teacher hey so let me let me
say this okay let me end this with this
you cannot solve a pandemic's worth
of psychological issues in your students
it's too big
if you're a nurse if you're a teacher if
you're an hr representative if you are
fill in the blank
you cannot hold the weight
the psychological the physical the
emotional the spiritual weight of the
people in your presence that you're
responsible for
in this case you cannot solve
the current the soon-to-be and way in
the future psychological challenges of
the pandemic with these young people you
can't hold all that
what you can do is love everybody in
your circle
really well right now and that starts
with you being
well and i love what nagatsuki sisters
say
wellness is not a state of being it's an
action it's a thing you do
right it is resting it is moving your
body it is remembering why you're doing
what you're doing and what you're doing
and how you're doing it and how can i
maximize the things that i love and how
can i
minimize the things that i hate and then
how can i hose my boots off when i get
home
go inside the house be with the people i
love and then go to bed
right and begin that process of i can't
fix it i can't
fix it all it's not all weighing on me
it's not all weighing on me
and then you start aiming back into
sleep
right check out this book um we'll link
to it in the show notes burn out the
secret to unlocking the stress cycle
with nagaski sisters it's incredible
it's a good read
um and thank you so much amanda for your
heart
who you are as a teacher who you are as
a human being
and what you're trying to do and i want
you to hear me say
you've been caring for these students
for 18 months
you've been caring for these students
for a long long time
now it's time to stop stop stop keep
caring for them
care for them today and caring for them
today starts with you caring for you
you caring for you you getting a gang of
people that are in your community that
you love
and that you all walk through this thing
together and then when you feel yourself
starting to
to stress about what's going to happen
10 years from now or five years from now
or this time next year we're gonna
just stop and say not my circus i can't
do anything about
what's gonna happen ten years from now i
can only take care of me right now i can
only love my students
right now bring yourself back bring
yourself back you're gonna practice this
over and over
you're gonna practice it i just hit the
microphone sorry you're gonna practice
it over and over and over you're gonna
get better and better at it thank you so
much for your heart